[Applause]
what else we got
trump wants to ban tick tock
not only does trump want to ban it now
he might back off because microsoft
wants to buy it this is the craziest
[ __ ]
boy this bill gates a bad [ __ ]
it's a bad [ __ ] right here bro
that bill gates a bad [ __ ] why
is a bad [ __ ]
listen i don't have any proof to this is
just like what i'm assuming
okay i this is
pure speculation conspiracy
bill gates does not have a social media
platform he has linkedin
but linkedin i don't see his social
media it's like it's not you can't move
culture with linkedin right
you move culture sway elections with
social media platforms
fastest growing social media platform on
the planet tick tock tick tock
you get america's youth with the tick
tock right
it's like facebook was the young
people's app
right then instagram came out and now
facebook is like oh this is old people
on facebook
yep now tick tock is out and eventually
instagram is gonna be looked at like the
old [ __ ]
yeah so here bill gates this is the
conspiracy that i'll just make up
bill gates gets trump
and other people to say that tick tock
is being used by the chinese government
to mine our data
right okay it's not owned by the chinese
government but any company that operates
within china and is a chinese company
owned by the chinese
it's owned by the chinese government in
other way at any point in time can they
be like yo we need the data
etc some people are saying that what
they're using is they're using the kids
to see what their parents politics are
oh interesting so like if the kids are
doing like cool
trump posters or cool you know hillary
or cool biden like posts etcetera dances
that kind of
you find what the political views of the
parents are because when you're a kid
your politics always reflect your
parents right always
yeah right you go to college maybe [ __ ]
starts to get mixed up when you're like
14 years old she's like oh dad likes
trump i like trump
i think gates is like i need to be in
the social media game
yeah or the people who run microsoft if
it's not gates day today we need to be
in the social media game
go say that china's using this data
against us
you know some nefarious purposes yeah
and they could be very well could be
they can't own this company and have it
be this popular in america
make sure china leaves this company
divest from the company or at least the
u.s
part of it and then i'll buy the company
yeah now this is where it gets really
good who was just in front of congress
recently
all the heads of except him except
bill gates why is mark zuckerberg jeff
bezos
the google dude who else there's one
more of them there right
yeah i can't remember it was amazon jack
dorsey
maybe i don't know jack dorsey's amazon
google uh
facebook and one other guy i can't
remember who it doesn't matter bill
gates not there at all
yeah nobody more entrenched than oh
exactly apple
oh yeah tim cook nobody more entrenched
in tech than bill gates why is bill
gates not there right
but he's making a vaccine or some [ __ ]
why is he not there yeah they're worried
about monopolistic practices from those
companies
apparently not microsoft so now
zugerberg can't even go say i'll put in
a bid for
tick-tock because you were just in front
of congress
for having monopolistic practices so if
he's really playing this level chess
where he gets
zuckerberg to look like this big
monopolistic [ __ ]
so he can't make the pitch for tick-tock
and then you come in and then save the
day yeah
none of those other big companies that
could easily afford tick tock can go buy
it because now
they might have too much market share or
whatever the [ __ ] it is they just gotta
lay low for a second
so he spoils their meal
and then go scoops it up on the low
potentially one thing
that i please poke pull calls yeah
india also banned tick tock and he's
been on tick tock weirdly america
copied india which is rare but india
banned tick tock for that exact same
reason
chinese government too much data we're
not doing it so doesn't that lend some
kind of credence you think to the idea
that it's not just america doing this
it's also happening with other countries
i think i agree with you 100
yeah um and i think the illusion with
american
social media platforms is that they
don't share the data with the government
right but i think that is a complete
illusion i think they share with
everybody
i think they share it with the american
government not everybody
but like for example facebook i think
they'll also sell it is what i'm saying
oh they can sell it to advertisers maybe
but like
i think it operates in a little bit
different way because i don't think the
advertisers are doing so much like you
know swaying election or that kind of
correct whereas like america might give
tim cook a call and go yo we need some
data on that apple music [ __ ] yeah
we don't know who's buying what this
happened for whatever reason who knows
why
i don't know how you even manipulate an
election yet we gotta do some research
yeah i don't know how you do it with
that data
that being said i think it's entirely
possible that they're using it to to
to data mine and i think it's entirely
possible that they don't want to
they don't want china to have all that
data yes i think that's
possible plausible i think that's a fact
and my theory
is i don't care how much money you're
giving to
giving away after you die if you are at
any point in your life the richest
person in the world
you got some sociopathic [ __ ] going on
right you enjoy being the top dog
on all fronts bill gates has fallen
pretty far in that race
bezos is the guy now and i think on some
level if you're
a tech giant who was for years the
richest person on earth
you're looking at this like i don't know
what the [ __ ] you guys think this is but
don't think i can't just come shut
it down also cook jobs
whoever i'm the [ __ ] guy don't forget
that so as soon as he sees this [ __ ]
starting to pop off in india i think
he's like okay
let's start lining up the chess pieces
let's start what is it exactly to your
point
what will get us a ton of market share
in the same way zuckerberg bought
instagram what's the next closest
move i can do to replicate that let's
buy tick-tock these guys are all going
in front of congress
they did put decades ago i think
microsoft was under the microscope for
monopolistic practices yeah they had to
back off let's go we're back in the game
it's been 20 years
these guys are all under the microscope
let's [ __ ] go i'm gonna be top dog
again don't [ __ ] think
i've backed out of this game i'm the guy
that was my thinking it was like a
sociopathic like
some ego yeah some ego [ __ ] yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
because what i didn't understand is why
microsoft was the only one that was
going to buy them it's like
why couldn't any company was willing to
put up the money by them
yeah that's just good to understand like
why just microsoft why did and why did
the article specifically come out like
that why isn't it why wasn't it
tick tock up for purchase in the states
let trump buy it well not trump but like
let
uh what's your man's name with the
mavericks let marcum buy it like why
can't any other billionaires just buy
them no it's true why does microsoft
specifically have to buy this true
they can't be the only people interested
now it could be and now again real
conspiratorial it could be that gates
has a
certain relationship with the us and
that's why they let him making the
[ __ ] vaccines or whatever it is
isn't he like on the board for the
vaccine research for uh i think for the
pandemic in general like the pandemic
response i think he's like
involved with and that's tied in with
the vaccine and that's the thing that's
like when i think i was talking about
this on rogan it's like
you reach a certain level of business
the united states of america where it's
too big for you not to be in bed with
the government
right it's too big and i like it that
way i don't want google
to be on its own i want them checked
by the government so that someone in
russia can't compromise the head of
google
and then all of a sudden google starts
feeding all that data and information
back to russia
i like that you reach a certain size
and a certain amount of success i'm not
talking about 100 million i'm talking
about
hundreds of billions of dollars in
business yeah and i like that the
government knocks on your door and
they're like hey
we just want to let you know that if you
want to keep doing this that's awesome
but we have an agreement now yeah we're
not going to take any money from you
we're actually going to let you get away
with a lot more than other people get
away with
but we might need to lean on you for
some because if it's really a problem
monopolistic practices
facebook has dominated social media for
10 years now since the second they
bought instagram
it's been a [ __ ] thing uh amazon
who's buying anything anymore
for years amazon has been the only place
you'll go shop well that was that was a
conversation that
uh i think robbie even brought up about
the culture war
was it you brought up or robbie was
saying that like
we were having this conversation with
like what america would always do is we
would always dictate
what the culture is right especially
through social media we create these
social media apps and they go to the
whole world
right and this is the first social media
app
not created by us and it's [ __ ]
incredible
like if you go on it it is addicting
non-stop swiping through it's hard to
even get out of the app
i don't know how to get out of it i just
i just delete it every time not delete
it but like do the thing where you like
close it out yeah yeah like i don't know
how to just get to the main screen
because there is no main screen
yeah it's just video i hate it but my my
girl can watch for
i love it i it's so swipe swipe swipe
laugh swipe
swipe swipe off my phone he had to you
were non-stop it's like you just
are you fall in the warm hole and then
two hours later it's like warm while you
were finding it
but the warm hole
you